[Musique]
beaucoup de toulousains au bord de la
garonne hier c'était autorisé mais
l'absence de gestes barrière alors que
le virus se propage dans la ville a
poussé la préfecture à fermer les quais
à compter d'aujourd'hui
on a déjà un contexte de dégradation est
le constat de ces mouvements de
personnes risquent d'accélérer cette
dégradation si on ne fait rien même
scène hier après midi à paris sur les
quais de seine là aussi c'était c'était
bondé difficile de résister à la
tentation d'un verre entre amis au
soleil sachant que c'est peut-être le
dernier week-end de liberté avant
l'éventuelle reconfirme en local dans la
capitale comportement des contrôles a
demandé au préfet des vingt départements
particulièrement surveillés pour le coc
b19 de contrôle et les mesures en
vigueur qu'à 17h30 fin de la partie en à
peine un quart d'heure le rideau tombe
paris c'est un à dunkerque impossible de
sortir ce week end
du moins sans attestation de déplacement
dérogatoire nice aussi retrouve le
confinement et les rues désertes comme
lors des épisodes précédents
j'approuve la stratégie du gouvernement
qui consiste à essayer de tout faire
pour l'éviter
maintenant on voit bien il est
vraisemblable que sur les vingt
départements qui sont aujourd'hui les
plus à risque dont les huit de l'île de
france
il va falloir prendre des mesures de
restriction supplémentaire
est-ce qu'on va tout droit vers ce
fameux confinement partiel le week end
oui ou non
rien n'est décidé sinon rien oui c'est à
chaque fois je reviens régulièrement
chez vous dès la gentillesse de
m'inviter à chaque jeudi ce n'est pas
décider vraiment rien n'est décidé on
dit aux habitants de dunkerque et de
nice vous pouvez vous entassez dans les
bus dans les tramways
vous pouvez aller travailler vous pouvez
aller dans la cantine de l'entreprise en
semaine parce qu'il ya pas de virus en
semaine mais le week-end alors que vous
pourriez aller au grand air là où il ya
le moins de virus vous êtes enfermé et à
des contrôles de police qui verbalisent
à tout va avant le panneau
c'est le confinement après la liberté
théoule sur mer dans les alpes maritimes
est frappé par les mesures de
restriction saint raphaël
non alors certains ont décidé de
franchir le pas je crois qu'on n'aura
jamais atteint une situation aussi
grotesque dans notre pays depuis
longtemps
plus inquiétant encore dans ce dossier
l'avancé des théories complotistes un
peu plus d'un français sur trois pensent
que le ministère de la santé est de
mèche avec l'industrie pharmaceutique
pour cacher la nocivité des vaccins et
42% estiment probable que la crise
sanitaire fournissent l'occasion
gouvernement de surveiller et de
contrôler les citoyens nous allons
mettre en place une organisation à
travers ce que j'appellerais un pass
sanitaire c'est à dire on va demander à
ce que d'abord les gens sans registre
pour faciliter vous savez le système d'
alerte est ce que vous comprenez ces
électeurs de gauche qui ne veulent plus
faire barrage alors moi je vais vous
dire une chose
j'ai eu ce qu'on appelle une sensibilité
de gauche
et si j'ai rejoint emmanuel macron c'est
parce que je pensais que c'était la
meilleure personne pour la porter et
aujourd'hui je suis fier de notre bilan
donc faut pas le lier au vaccin c'est
plus complexe que ça c'est un ensemble
qui permettra de mieux tester de
d'identifier les gens et d'utiliser sont
aussi les tests si vous avez monsieur
maquereau en face de madame le pen ce
sera madame le pen cette fois c'est vrai
ça vraiment j'en suis convaincu c'est
d'ailleurs le sujet si on veut se
retrouver l'année prochaine dans un an
avec une guerre civile ouverte dans ce
pays ben faut voter macron le plus grand
prédateur de l'arctique
à peut-être trouvé plus fort que lui
le changement climatique menace l'ours
polaire sur ses terres
la banquise est en train de fondre le
privant de son lieu de vie parce que
macro est celui qui met le pen au
pouvoir donc il faut battre monsieur
macron dès le premier tour à la
recherche de nourriture certains ours
blanc ont gagné les forêts se sont
accouplés avec des ours bruns créant
cette nouvelle espèce baptisée pizzly un
ours polaire qui n'en est plus vraiment
un